it was a triumph of social media
marketing
a feel-good exuberance mob in new york's
iconic grand central station
at the dawn of the instagram age
today is media in general it's not any
more newspaper magazine
tv radio today's media means you have to
attract
for attract a community
you really have you have to talk with
them every day
when montclair's chief executive rhema
raffini staged his new york spectacular
sent cyclists into milan's velodrome
or took over the lincoln center he'd
already
stepped outside the traditional
boundaries of the catwalk
into the realm of the theater welcome
to the winter palace tapping into the
social media zeitgeist
that had helped propel an almost
bankrupt french ski
wear company into the upper echelons of
global fashion
[Music]
now he's taking a new risk
this is bloomberg turn around join me to
see how raymar ruffini
is changing engines in mid-flight at
montclair
the luxury puffer jacket maker
[Music]
in 2018 raffini announced he was going
to ditch the business model
that had supported the turnaround of the
failing company he'd bought in 2003
when he propelled it from a mid-ranking
ski gear maker
to a business among the most profitable
listed
luxury companies in the world
but raffini has refused to rest on his
laurels
in an effort to prepare the company for
the next stage of expansion
and turbocharged sales he announced
a new way of doing business
instead of spring summer winter fall
men's and women's
he now has a collection every month with
eight
different designers he dubbed it genius
for me it's an incredible instrument of
communication because
it could have something to talk about to
the market every month
with famous designers nice images of
products
very innovative products strange
products so
in its incredible reach of contents
this approach this collection allows
them to
with great frequency be sharing
something new be bringing different
influencers targeting different sub
segments of their uh
of their consumer base and it gives them
a lot to talk about on social media it's
probably the most valuable asset
that they have on social media today
they really are working
on what montclair will be in five years
time
so i think that this approach long-term
approach
could be a guarantee that they could
still have room to grow
welcome to your own office david tweed
what i wanted to ask
first is what is the essence of genius
so you're really content content on
content the people they need content and
the people need ideas then at the end of
the day they need also product to go
into the stores but
you know our strategy is based to
attract people every month in the stores
but not only to sell a jacket but it's
you know
also to participate to our to our let's
call festival you know
and again our our strategy is based on
all generation
means every month we like we want to
talk with different generations
the strategy seemed to work the year of
the launch
sales rose by a fifth the fastest pace
in three years and the share price has
staged a recovery
after its steady ascent stalled briefly
at the end of last year
the way that it works is that they're
using the base of their history
but allowing creativity individual to
individually to those collaborators
that reaches a much younger audience
speed of audience
is very much a cachet on digital and
e-commerce
and creates a buzz around other products
that are available under the montclair
brand
like this puffer jacket for dogs a snip
at 425
in the fourth quarter of 2018 montclair
was the biggest gainer in ranking of
luxury searches compiled by liszt
a global fashion search platform
genius diffusion lines drop monthly and
were responsible for the brand's biggest
spikes in both
social engagement and search volume
[Music]
genius is not just about selling more
products
genius is about how do i give something
for my consumers to talk about on a
regular basis
right one of the challenges of
traditional luxury is there's an
inherent conservatism in some ways right
i need to
stand for something consistent i can't
be refreshing all the time yet that
makes it difficult in the social media
world
what do i talk about every week and if
i'm not talking to my consumers every
week they're not listening
so this these collaborations the the
frequent launches
allow them to have something to talk
about you know represent
less than 10 of their sales a day but i
would expect
half of what's discussed on social media
if you can measure it another
crucial thing in the fashion industry
today is that you have something
that is limited today everybody wants in
the market
something that is limited you know you
collect watches
you collect shoes you could whatever so
it's a trend
for me it's very important for the
genius also that the fact that
every month you have a collection you
have a designer and that's it then you
cannot buy anymore
coming up we'll talk more with rhema
raffini about the first time he
transformed montclair
back in 2003 when it was a french ski
ware company
that had seen better days this was a
fantastic example out to redesign the
company we keep
to keep the roots as as close as you can
in 2003 roofini bought montclair
a 50 year old french sportswear company
on the brink of insolvency
montclair's sales were less than 50
million euros at the time
last year turnover was 1.4 billion
[Music]
actually the montclair i was very
familiar with the brand
because uh in italy in the 70s was very
very popular
and i bought my first month leno whether
it was like 14 15 years old i was living
out of my own town is como my house was
a little bit out of coma like six seven
kilometers
and every morning i used my motorcycle
to go to the school
when i was 14 15 at that time was much
more cold than today
and i always use this jacket very bright
very shiny
montclair is named after monster de
clermont
an alpine town in france founded in 1952
it made tense and quilted sleeping bags
and its workers wore quilted coats to
keep warm
mountaineer lionel terry saw them and
suggested montclair outfit his
1954 expedition to k2
considered the world's most dangerous
mountain to climb
akili compagnoni and linole were the
first to successfully reach its summit
in 1954.
kitted out in montclair the brand became
a favorite among the jet set
bridget bardo jackie kennedy
the empress of iran
but when raffini bought it the company
was on the skids
buffeted from competition from the likes
of prada
and the north face that time was a
trendy brand but it was
mainly a ski wear brand so you had basic
colors i remember you had
yellow red blue but nothing
to compare with today of course yes
after a while i think in the
the end of the eighties beginning in
nineties they lost their way
it was still i think a french brand at
that time
and then uh mr ruffini came over the
brand and decided to
to buy it so i'm looking for something
real with the strong roots
and after six seven months looking for
the market
i realized montclair was could possible
available and after one year talking
i bought the brand and this was a
fantastic
fantastic example how to redesign the
company where we keep
to keep the roots as as close as you can
i think you talk about the dna a lot
right yeah a lot because i think you
have to respect especially when you have
a brand
they have a very strong dna yeah wired
through
this on the garbage or whatever i think
is very important to keep the dna
to try to be modern to be try to improve
everything
but the dna is very very important
[Music]
raffini decided to move the company here
to milan
italy's fashion capital people tell me
though that that you
are considered to be a master in brand
rejuvenation okay so
what did you do when you first went into
montclair in 2003 and you looked at the
range
and thought okay this is how we're going
to take this brand forward
how did you do it what were the the nuts
and bolts of that
honestly nothing special come on
honestly i
went there i started working really on
the small things
you know i started working on first in
the product in the quality
to redesign the ideas because at the end
of the day you
you need you need a big brand but you
need also a contemporary product
[Applause]
this is the global puffer jacket this
was remarfini's
big idea to take a piece of outerwear
that was normally
only used on the slopes when you're
skiing or in alpine expeditions
and turn it into a luxury item that
people would like to wear
in town you developed this idea of the
global down
jacket yes because for me it was
important not only to remain on this
kind of stores not only used for hiking
or climbing but also i think it was a
big potential to use this product also
walk into the street
you know that's why i start working on
quality and weight on performance
on all these kind of things i read once
you were looking at people in an air
in an airline or in in an airplane that
just arrived from new york
yes because since when i bought the
company i bought one jacket i use
soon i realized it was impossible to use
because one day you go new york
is cold maybe it's okay with your jacket
but then you fly you
fly to tokyo is 22 degrees you don't
know where you put the jack is huge
you don't have enough space on the back
to put the jacket
and i say lightness is very important
you know softness and everything on that
i really work on technology i really
work on weight i really work on this
kind of thing and then i start
i start walking around the water to
understand what is the potential of this
brand and understand which kind of
kind of people they can use they can use
in the city or not
only in the mountain and then after one
year i
really try to move the brand from the as
i say support good stores
into more luxury environment
he got the product right raffini
executed the next part of his plan
the gam rouge line for women the first
time skewer had been presented as
fashion
followed by gambler for men
[Music]
with each show becoming more of an event
an autumn forest for the girls
a strobing striptease for the boys
[Music]
to say nothing of the 2009 grand central
station flash mob
an event almost perfectly timed with
instagram
becoming a thing then came the stores
this is the via monte napoleoni it is
without doubt the most prestigious
luxury fashion street in
all of italy prada ferragamo
armani so it makes absolute sense that
when montclair decides to expand and
open a flagship store in milan
it chooses this location yes after two
three years you know late 2008 i decided
to open my first tour i say where i
opened the stores you know could be you
know
champ elizae or fubu santonero we
decided to go
straight to to the most luxury street in
europe basically
one of the most luxury street in europe
we open in small stores
in in santo norris honestly we feel
since when we opened the doors that the
brand was good
good receipts from this kind of customer
you know we have line outside every day
basically
and managing your own distribution
though that's something that's also key
isn't it
i think in the beginning this was
another turning point i decided to
basic cancel all distribution agent
license really i think my dream was
really to control 100 percent
my since the day one my everything
and we can sell all the partner because
you know it's quite conflict of interest
i want to build up a brand that they
won't sell sell and sell
and i start my retail business my alone
i open my store directly monotone in
paris open master
all around the world from china japan
united states
i mean it was much more difficult but i
the good thing i control the process i
think control
everything have this fast feedback from
the market understand what's going on
especially at the beginning when we have
like three four or five stores i call
them every night you don't
understand what's going on now it's
little bit more difficult but with data
you can have the same feedback
there is a real concerted effort to open
up retail you also
saw a move away from the wholesale right
uh so into that retail transition so
this was the period i would say of real
expansion becoming a global brand
right and and really putting down
starting to put down a lot of flags here
in asia
you can see the importance of the retail
strategy here
retail sales the pale orange bars
easily outpace wholesale the bright
orange bars
still ahead how rima riffini developed
his china strategy
this is montclair's hong kong flagship
store
it's one of about half a dozen outlets
in the city and
it is vast we're looking at 500 square
meters
of retail space it was the biggest
outlet in all of asia
until the beginning of the year when a
bigger store opened in singapore
ruffini thinks that china is where the
growth and luxury is going to be
montclair is just getting started three
four years ago
i decided that in china it was better to
sell brand
brand perception and sell jacket we're
not open to many stores
i think we have huge possibility to
increase our size of the store increase
number of doors
[Music]
nearly a decade after buying the company
raffini decided it was time to take
montclair public
a second attempt after the first was
foiled by the market upheaval
surrounding the greek crisis it was a
way for rafini to arrange an exit for
his private equity investor
without having to turn to new private
equity funding
since the beginning of private equity in
my company they helped me to
buy the company at the beginning was
meeted and carlisle
that is an american privateer came to
the
to the company and after that as you
know they need an exit
basically in uh caroline late 2009 2010
it will be
when we need to exit at least apart i
don't want to start again to make
you know raising the another private
tech and say okay let's try to go public
in the end carlisle sold its 45 stake to
french private equity company eurozio
in the winter of 2013 montclair has its
initial public offering
it turns out to be the most successful
in europe that year the
shares rise 41 percent on the first day
of trading
valuing the company at 3.6 billion euro
about 5 billion us dollars rhema ruffini
becomes 1 billion richer
eurozao hung onto its stake for eight
years selling the last five percent in
march
over the years its investment generated
a return of 1.4 billion euros
and an internal rate of return of 43
[Music]
the ipo funds helped back the expansion
into china that started in 2011
a market that partly inspired rafini to
launch genius
[Music]
raffini says the key is first of all to
establish the brand
and the stores will follow i think the
future of
luxury is for sure china i think we are
still very small in china
three four years ago i decided that
in china it was better to sell brand
brand perception and sell jacket
we're not open too many stores i think
we have huge possibility to increase our
size of the store increased number of
doors but the one we got
less than i think 30 stores so right now
for you china is about
selling brand perception it's like
you're preparing the market i think it's
very important because for sure in 10
years china will be the biggest market
i don't know if in 10 years i will be
there you know
it means the most important things to
remain strong in china
is to build up a very strong brand for
sure the mac will be
the biggest
it's a prediction shared by others in
the industry i think it's important to
recognize the secular trend
of the growing affluent in china so
there is a lot of
news and volatility that we read about
the trade war right
we if we were sitting here in 2013 we
would have been talking about
anti-corruption
which actually took a big gifting
portion of the luxury goods market away
right and then all of a sudden there was
a lot of naysayers on the china luxury
market
but actually what was still happening
and still happening today is a very
consistent growth of the chinese
affluent
and that's why we predict there'll be up
to 40 percent
of the global luxury market by 2023
is the secular growth of this segment so
there'll be some ups and downs but
the overall trend is still there 40 from
what uh it's about 32 today
the chinese market is vast but not
necessarily easy
like when dolce and gabbana released a
marketing video depicting a chinese
beauty trying to eat pizza with
chopsticks
it didn't help the brand's reputation
when one of the founders let fly with an
attack on china's netizens
a boycott ensued that's an issue when
chinese shoppers are estimated to
account for
at least a third of luxury sales and
two-thirds of the industry's growth
how do you go about avoiding making
cultural errors in a market which is
let's face it it's a foreign market
i think the cb4 since the first day we
decided to go directly in every market a
team
is very important team you build there
is very important because
i only stay i always say to to the guys
we have to be domestic
because this is very important because
the culture the language everything is
totally different i cannot talk
the same language in japan in seoul or
in beijing even if
it is one hour flight the country is so
different that you need something local
to help you
but at the same time you have to be
domestic my for sure
you need a global vision because
otherwise you become a domestic company
means is the mix you know and the team
you have in the region
is very very important it's a fine line
to balance you know i think if you've
seen recent scandals
dolce gabbana it's important to have a
sensitivity to understand who your
consumers are
haven't in in place some of the
governance and guard rails
to help contain the conversation to be
appropriate and inspiring for who those
consumers but if you do
make a mistake then how do you react to
it i'm sorry
right it's sometimes i mean i think
there's you know
there are probably many approaches to
this being upfront
and and straightforward and not letting
you know the the thing fester for a long
time
it was probably one of the better ways
to execute right in the face of a
significant error mistake
despite montclair success questions do
remain about whether it's a risk to base
an entire business
on one product a puffer jacket we see
huge growth potential in the puffer
jacket its
heritage its history its base its
foundation
there isn't a huge amount of competition
out there so we would say that there's
definitely longevity there and even
around
the new design implementations and one
of collaborations that they have going
on
the puffer jacket provides the base so
the answer would be no we see
long-term growth prospect for the puffy
jacket
genius was as much a device to create a
conversation with customers
as it was to shake up his own company
after 10 years
my feeling was everybody's sleep a
little bit in the company
and i think we have to we say we have to
change something we have to attract
different customers we have to
we thought everyone was a bit of sleep
in the company yes because after 10
years
also myself yeah also i said because the
business was always the same you have
two fashion shows here you know
spring summer autumn winter and then the
upper spring summer autumn winter spring
summer to wind
i think this this war they need much
more energy
and that's why we decide to move our
ideas from
seasonal business into monthly business
for raffini the biggest risk facing his
business
isn't an over-reliance on a single
product or the vagaries of a far away
market
it's at home the big risk i think is
us the team i think as i said before the
world change
very fast if you if you if we not follow
the word
we're gonna lose
[Music]
you